Good morning everyone, thanks for joining. This is our week one kickoff for the APAC quarter. We have 30 minutes and three things to cover: the quarterly gap to plan, our top deals with a focus on Tokyo Daimaru and Mumbai SMB, and the action commitments for this week. Aisha, please kick us off with the dashboard. Hiroshi, you are up right after on Daimaru, and Priya, please be ready to walk Mumbai. Wei, I will pull you in for capacity allocation at the end. Let's go.
Thanks Mei Lin. You are looking at the APAC quarterly tracker as of this morning. The top tile shows we are at 92 percent of plan, which is an 8 point gap to where we need to be. Most of that gap is concentrated in two markets. Tokyo is down 12 points year to date, and that is almost entirely the Daimaru renewal slipping. Mumbai is actually up 4 points but partner contracts are creating real drag and slowing close cycles. Singapore, Shanghai, and Sydney are all in the green.
If you look at the second view, our top five deals by annual recurring revenue this quarter are: number one Tokyo Daimaru renewal, number two Mumbai SMB cluster of 12 deals which together exceed Daimaru in total ARR, number three Shanghai retail tech expansion, number four Singapore financial services, and number five Sydney enterprise food and beverage. The risk-adjusted forecast puts us at 96 percent if Daimaru lands this quarter, and only 88 percent if it slips.
Thanks Aisha, that is super clear. Two questions before we move on. First, how confident are we in the Mumbai upside given the partner contract drag, and second, are there any deals I am missing that could move into the top five if something accelerates?
On Mumbai, the 12 deals are all late stage and Priya is the best person to size the confidence. On hidden upside, there are two Shanghai retail tech expansions that could enter the top five if the customer signs the master agreement in March. Otherwise the top five is stable.
Good. Let's go to Tokyo. Hiroshi, please walk us through the Daimaru picture honestly. What changed and what is the path to save it this quarter?
Thanks Mei Lin. The picture on Daimaru is red right now. Last Thursday our long-standing procurement contact moved to a different division, and the new procurement owner is reviewing all vendor contracts from scratch, including ours. She has paused the renewal pending her review, which she has signaled will take six to eight weeks. That puts us at meaningful risk of slipping into next quarter. There are three specific objections she has raised: pricing benchmark, integration cost and timeline, and lack of an executive sponsor on our side.
That is tough. On the exec sponsor piece, I can be in front of Daimaru leadership within two weeks if that helps. What is your read on whether that moves the needle?
Yes, that absolutely moves the needle. Their CIO specifically asked who our exec sponsor is. On pricing, we have room to give a concession band Aisha and I can model. On integration, that is the one I need Wei for, because it is technical and the customer has asked for a live integration demo. I would like to host a Friday ad-hoc with Wei in Tokyo to brainstorm and lock the save plan before next week's triage.
Great. Hiroshi owns the Daimaru save plan with Wei on technical and me on the exec sponsor introduction. Let's move to Mumbai. Priya, please walk us through the SMB cluster.
Thanks Mei Lin. You are seeing the Mumbai SMB tracker. We have 12 deals in late stages right now. Seven of them are ready to close, meaning all technical objections are resolved and we are waiting on contracts. The other five have technical objections I cannot resolve solo. The total ARR across all 12 is roughly 1.2 times Daimaru, so this cluster matters more than people think.
On the seven ready-to-close deals, the real blocker is partner contracts. Two of our SI partners have contract templates stuck in legal review on their side, and that is gating signature. I would like to ask Mei Lin to escalate to Aisha's counterpart in legal operations. On the five deals needing technical help, Wei is the right person and I'd like two days of his time this week.
Happy to help on both fronts. I can carve out Tuesday and Wednesday this week for Priya's five SMB deals — that should be enough to walk each customer through the integration patterns and get to objections-resolved. And as I said in chat, I am committed to Friday for the Daimaru save plan. So my week is: Mon catch-up, Tue and Wed Mumbai, Thu triage, Fri Tokyo. If anything urgent comes up beyond that, please flag it now.
Perfect, Wei. Priya, I will escalate the partner-contract issue today to legal ops and copy you on the thread. Aisha, on your side, how quickly can the dashboard reflect the Mumbai partner-contract delays as a tracked risk so leadership sees this?
I can add a partner-contract risk tag by end of day today and refresh the dashboard by Friday morning so it is ready for next week's cross-regional sync.
Excellent. Let's recap so the Facilitator captures it cleanly. Action one: Hiroshi owns Daimaru save plan, hosts Friday ad-hoc with Wei and me. Action two: I escalate the Mumbai partner-contract delay to legal ops today. Action three: Wei dedicates Tuesday and Wednesday to Priya's five SMB deals. Action four: Aisha tags partner-contract risk in the dashboard today and refreshes by Friday. Anything else before we close?
Nothing more from me. Thanks team.
All good, thanks Mei Lin.
Great. See everyone Thursday at triage. Take care.